We’re trying to measure gravity between
two microscopic objects — so micron-sized
objects, one-millionth of a meter in size,
so about one-one-hundredth the width of a
human hair. And we do this by actually levitating
a glass sphere that’s five microns in diameter
in a high vacuum chamber. And we levitate
it with a laser, so actually the laser, the
photons or the light in the laser, pushes
on the microsphere or this five-micron glass
sphere hard enough to hold it up against gravity
and float it in the center of our vacuum chamber.
And because it’s then sitting in our vacuum
chamber, we can decouple it from all the forces
that you would get if you were in the environment
and you had air pushing against you and other
things that could degrade the ability to see
these very tiny forces from gravitational
interactions or gravity-like interactions
that we’re looking for. So to do this we
need lasers. We need to be able to have an
optical table where we can take a laser, focus
it inside of our vacuum chamber. Once we bring
the light to a focus, then you get a very
intense laser light which is strong enough
to hold up this microsphere against gravity.
We then actually drop these microspheres in-vacuum.
So we smear them on to the bottom of a glass
cover slip. We shake that cover slip very
hard and some of these microspheres fall off
and they fall under gravity. And a very tiny
fraction of them will actually fall through
this micron-sized focus of our laser. So the
analogy might be that it’s like dropping
a basketball of the Empire State Building
and expecting it to fall through the hoop
on the ground floor. So this happens very
rarely, but obviously we can drop very many
of these microspheres and some of them will
fall through that hoop and become trapped.
Once they’re trapped, then they’re very
well decoupled from the environment and we
can see these extremely tiny forces that we
want to see interacting on them. So we bring
a dense test mass nearby, so a gold test mass
or a very dense material that’s also microns
in size to micron separations and then we
look for some attractive force as we start
to get that test mass very near the microsphere
that’s held in our laser trap.